hey guys so it's time to announce the
winners of the ipod shuffle now as you
guys know I picked one winner from
Twitter and one from YouTube and all you
have to do is be a subscriber so are you
ready to hear the winners now before I
announce the winners a lot of you guys
had questions on how i was going to
choose the winner it's completely random
and literally close to my eyes click my
mouse a bunch of times and point it to
away what do you know it's you guys so
let me tell you who won frommer Twitter
we have worked kula and from youtube we
have sweet voice 94 so congratulations
guys feel free to choose your color and
if Apple let me return it for the color
that you want then
yeah I'll do that so I'll be trying to
get just you guys shortly and now it's
time for the live show so head on over
to justin.tv / I just doon weeks inside
and I'll see you guys might show and
that's it that's all I've got see guys
show